okay so we have another one here
uh if you cheat on your girl you will
need to understand she will cheat you
put this in bold she will cheat on you
even if it's just for revenge
not always true although true sometimes
so women that subscribe to you know the
forward notion of toxic feminism and
what's good for the goose is good for
the gander
uh they they will do it but once they do
it that's it like once a woman cheats
your relationship with her ends that is
[ __ ] it it is over she's betrayed
your trust
done
oh you can't say that because if you do
it then it should be the same no
because
it doesn't change a guy's a guy can
easily
easily and again i've talked to hundreds
of guys that have done this can easily
go outside of the marriage
uh you know
they'll do it when they're on business
trips they'll do it when they're doing
whatever at a conference it doesn't
matter they they figure out ways to do
it
and they still come home and they kiss
their wife and they love them and they
have sex with them and all that sort of
stuff
it's not it's not foolish like
this individual claims uh it's going to
happen to assume otherwise is foolish
it's not if you can't handle that don't
cheat or you should probably break up
again you should probably break up
so
in the animal kingdom
this is what's funny so in the animal
kingdom
for every pregnancy so for every birth
of an animal cow horse sheep
donkey doesn't matter whatever it is
[ __ ] whale
there's there's roughly i think
somewhere between 13 to 15
um instances of sexual intercourse okay
in humans for every instance of a
pregnancy and by the way
with today's world women and pregnancies
and and and terminate them
because they're too lazy to be on birth
control whatever but
the the no the instances of sexual
intercourse that result in a pregnancy
is well over a thousand okay
humans are not like we don't have sex
for the purpose of reproduction it's for
connection for social reasons
for hierarchical reasons there's there's
a whole bunch of reasons why humans do
it and then if you add in all the ways
that men and women have sex that can't
possibly result in a pregnancy like oral
and or whatever it is you want to add to
it then that number probably goes to
2000.
so
say just just break up or you don't
understand the morality or relatively
wrong wrong wrong blah blah blah like
this one is over here
it's just short-sighted and it's foolish
you just don't understand human nature
if you want to be
in a relationship with a chick and you
want to be monogamous choose it don't
have it enforced on you don't have
somebody you know beat on you you don't
do that you're going to break up and
it's going to be over sort of thing
you know what cheat on her and see what
she does you know you'll find out pretty
quickly but if
if you want to be monogamous then do it
it's entirely up to you if you if you're
a high value guy and you have options
and you choose to be monogamous good for
you she should worship the [ __ ]
ground that you walk on though i'll tell
you that
this other one over here
if you don't want to be monogamous don't
sorry if you don't want to be in a
monogamous relationship let her go
another let her go dude or break up with
her or leave her or find somebody better
it sounds like she's trying to be a good
girlfriend even though you treat her
horribly he treats her he treats her
horribly by providing for her an
excellent lifestyle taking her on trips
taking her to fancy restaurants
how is that treating her horribly right
that's this this like laser focus
is so bizarre to me now that i've
unplugged and i actually see the code in
the matrix i know some of you guys
understand that are watching this too
right anyway she deserves to find
someone who'll treat her with respect
again taking her on expensive vacations
and trips dinners providing housing for
lovely furniture you know
that's not respecting a chick really
let her go he says if you have already
cheated on her and have no regrets you
don't love her let her go [ __ ]
[ __ ] this is somebody without
options that that does that doesn't
understand what drives attraction and
how humans work they just don't
understand they've watched too much
disney when they were kids
or they've lived in the united states
too long probably smashing back pizzas
and beers uh hope you don't regret your
decision later on down the road okay so
this next guy over here
i'm not sure i follow it just sounds
like you're rationalizing bad behavior
what if your girl said she just wants
some strange on the side and told you
she won't embarrass you she won't get
pregnant she'll make them wear condoms
and she won't fall in love with them
that's
see this is the blank slate what's good
for the goose is good for the gander
whatever you apply to men you should
apply to women
the
like any time you hear that [ __ ] what's
good for the goose is good for the
gander or what what happens to men you
know you can apply to women
idiots okay it is it is the most foolish
belief to think that men and women are
exactly the same and should operate
under the same standards they're just
not not even close
by your standards you should be okay
with this yes sexual differences aside
men out there aren't feel sorry most men
out there aren't filthy rich or have
celebrities you're right absolutely most
of them don't pulling this off with your
average check just doesn't seem feasible
i mean if you tell your girl this and
doesn't bat an eye then you find out she
started banging dudes on the side too
see this guy has no experience women
don't when women are truly in love with
you other guys are invisible they don't
they don't just bang dudes on the side
they can't okay the this new age
polyamory where you see these news
articles where it's this one huffle
upper with like four nerds sitting
around her and then you know six months
later the next article is uh or sorry
not six months let's say 15 months later
because the exact same one happened
where
one of the guys knocks up the girl and
then the other ones that didn't knock
her up get so embarrassed and jealous
that they end up harming the baby and
causing havoc in the relationship these
things don't work out they never work
out every single [ __ ] time it
collapses
i give you ishmael the bloodthirsty the
sultan of morocco sired over a thousand
children with several wives and hundreds
of concubines
and they were all okay with it okay
throughout history high value guys have
been able to do this give me one example
of a woman throughout history that ran a
harem of men they don't [ __ ] exist
they've never existed because it's not
normal
it's only today good for the goose is
good for the gander
what if she doesn't embarrass you she
won't get pregnant if she'll make them
wear a condom she won't fall in love
with them [ __ ] women can't do it
it's not possible
uh oh we have another check over here uh
moment someone cheats and the other
person finds out it's all over for both
of them if a woman says she forgives
question appears why makes no sense why
would she agree to share her man's time
attention see here we go her man's ty
see this chick actually gets it
why would she agree to share her man's
time attention and resources i'll tell
you why she'll agree because she can't
do better than this guy because women
want their high program as best and if
he's not giving away
his time attention and resources
to some variety on the side and it all
goes to her that's why
she doesn't understand that though it
makes no sense or ago she will always
have his cheating in the back of her
mind if she cared before she will think
about that cheating with every touch she
makes of her either she is lying or
probably is looking for doesn't get it
again you know this is another one of
these cat lady avatars
it's considered monogamous relationship
uh want to [ __ ] around at best well
all these idealized ideas about monogamy
man
you don't get it
you just don't get it these these
let's get for the goose is good for the
gander
tough call you should probably let her
go isn't fair to be cheating on her
shouldn't have moved in with her well
she probably shouldn't have moved in
with her at only 14 or 16 months or
whatever it was
right about that um
fair
what is fair like is it fair when a
woman
when a guy commits to a woman remodels
the kitchen moves her family in across
the ocean gives her the kids that she
wants and then she goes and [ __ ] off uh
with uh kevin from sales and you know
leaves the household you know like is
that fair
like there
there's nothing fair about
relationships
there just isn't you know you think that
there's fairness in it
dude you're plugged into the matrix man
you are plugged into the matrix
habadaba have a dabba dabba okay where's
this next one here we go rich good
advice although you sound like okay this
is the guy talking about the double
standard
uh
okay so this white knight says this is
to the girlfriend
uh she does not value or know her
self-worth how do you know that
how how do you know that
she's allowing him to treat her like a
doormat really again taking her out on
expensive vacations out to dinners
housing her in a beautiful apartment
all [ __ ] she couldn't do on her own
where she lives
she claims she wants a monogamous
relationship it doesn't want him to
cheat on her however
she knows about the times he has and she
has chosen yes this is a choice to stay
with him he now sees her as weak no he
doesn't there's there's nothing about
him that see that saw her as weak
he ness user was an option sorry girl
you were sorry girl this is like the
white knight line sorry girl
you are seeking love and this is not it
i am love i am built in love i'm such a
great guy why don't you why don't you
choose me
have some dignity and move on why are
you wasting your 20s on a player that
does not want to be with only you you
will never see never get these precious
years back you will always be a player
that does not love you
being player there's not like
a man is more than capable of loving a
woman
monogamous or not
again it's it's a choice monogamy is a
choice that you have to make guys if you
want to do it do it if you don't want to
do it don't do it it's your call move
the hell on i hate seeing women in this
situation of course because you're a
[ __ ] white knight
the guy's just pissed because he's got
the hot girl and he's able to do what he
wants around her
white knights plugged in white knights
unplug guys honestly
you want to level up in life you want to
get somewhere you want to get what you
want out of [ __ ] life unplug
i've got a chick here that says no
self-respected woman would ever put up
with that crap what a joke
really
you know the queen of england it's it's
it's known
that the duke edinburgh
her husband her consort
had openly gone outside of the marriage
several [ __ ] times
while they were together
in fact
rumor has it that they had a
conversation at one point where she said
whatever you got to do to stay in this
marriage you do
you do what you got to do just don't
embarrass the monarchy
but this but this wise uh individual
here again with a cat avatar an 11
subscriber says no no self-respecting
woman would ever put up with that crap
what a joke i'm sure that she's probably
sitting at home right now surrounded by
cats drinking boxed wine by herself
the platypus guy oh
where's the next guy here um
he's ready the [ __ ] uh when either a
man or woman does it it's betrayal no
it's not
when a woman goes outside it's betrayal
when a men go when a man goes outside
you can call it cheating a relationship
is a commitment and he's broken the
commitment he you can commit to a woman
completely
and totally
and still want to have some variety on
the side
there isn't a double standard she should
leave him yes there is
men and women are not the same you dummy
they're very very different
the sooner that you accept that
the better off you'll be
it's it's guys like this
that will go out get into a relationship
with the first girl that touches his pp
after one week
and then find out a few months later
that she's cheating on him
and then they'll go down the rabbit hole
of [ __ ]
they'll blackpill themselves hate
everything
you know refuse to accept reality
there isn't a double standard she should
leave him and be with me instead
okay dork
last guy um this is a dude he says wow
you really think women are okay with men
sleeping with other women even if she
did forgive him for cheating she's still
dying inside
sure
sure hey guys i really hope that you
enjoyed that short clip if you did
consider supporting the creation of
content by checking out my supplement
line pinned in the top comment below of
this video in the comments there's a
link to the unpluggedalpha.com forward
slash shop when you click through you'll
be able to land over here and the entire
lineup is broken down by category that
it performs best in estrogen metabolism
fat burning your foundational essentials
for health immune health performance and
testosterone support if you check out
with coupon code alpha 10 you'll get 10
off on your first order there's also the
option to use the subscribe and save
model where regular shipments will be
sent over to you on a regular basis and
that gives you a little bit of a
discount and your supplement facts are
always broken down over here thanks for
watching i hope you guys have an awesome
day and again check out that link it's
pinned in the top comment below in this
video peace out
you